[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime-doku von
Bild
hallo zusammen und herzlich willkommen
zu einer neuen Folge von Tatort
Deutschland ich bin Tony Hayer und ich
bin Mirko Kasimir schön dass ihr wieder
dabei seid wir machen heute eine
Zeitreise mit euch
und zwar in das Jahr 1927 am 21 mai um
22 Uhr 24 Uhr schreibt ein Amerikaner
Luftfahrtgeschichte Charles Lindberg hat
nonstop den Atlantik überquert und
landet in Paris er ist 33 Stunden zuvor
auf dem Flugplatz von Long Island in New
York gestartet
Lindberg Gerät in eisregenzonen die er
überwinden muss zeitweise kämpft er mit
starker Übermüdung um das Gewicht seiner
Maschine möglichst niedrig zu halten
verzichtet er auf ein Funkgerät und
einen Sextanten stattdessen fliegt er
nur mit einer Armbanduhr Karten und im
Kompass unter diesem historischen Abend
schließlich weist die Beleuchtung des
Eiffelturms ihm die letzte Wegstrecke
und Charles Lindberg landet in Paris er
kassiert ein Preisgeld von 25.000 Dollar
sein Triumph hilft den USA aus einer
Schockstarre man könnte auch sagen er
verdrängt ein Trauma aus den
Schlagzeilen denn nur wenige Tage vorher
hat ein unfassbarer Massenmord das Land
erschüttert und eigentlich ist es viel
zu früh um das grauenhafte Blutbad zu
vergessen dass ich am 18 mai in Barf
zugetragen hat das ist bis heute ein
provinzielles Städtchen anderthalb
Autostunden nordwestlich von Detroit im
US-Bundesstaat Michigan um 8:45 Uhr an
diesem Mittwoch im Frühjahr donnert eine
Explosion über den Ort sie hat ihren
Ursprung auf der Farm der Familie am
Ortsrand zum Gehöft gehören 185 Hektar
Land
über die Feldwege rattern an diesem
Morgen Rettungskräfte von Polizei und
Feuerwehr zu dem Hof der weit sichtbar
in Flammen steht noch während die
Einsatzkräfte und Nachbarn der Kiosk
versuchen das Feuer unter Kontrolle zu
bringen erschüttert eine weitere
Explosion die Kleinstadt diesmal hat es
die Grundschule getroffen die ersten
Helfer die es vom Hof der kiehhaus zur
elementary school von Bad geschafft
haben sind entsetzt vom Bild dass ich
ihnen bietet vom nördlichen Teil des
Gebäudes sind nur noch rauchende Trümmer
übrig
augenzeugen berichten später so
ein Haufen Kinder zwischen fünf und
sechs Jahren war unter den Trümmern des
Daches verschüttet worden einige hatten
ihre Arme herausgestreckt andere nur
ihre Beine nur wenige konnten ihre Köpfe
befreien vor lauter Schmutz gibt's und
Blut konnten wir niemanden erkennen wir
groben mit bloßen Händen nach den
Kindern einige konnten wir retten Eltern
irrten in der Ruine umher und suchten
ihre Kinder einige fanden sie auf dem
Schulhof wo sich Überlebende versammelt
hatten andere fanden nur noch die
Leichen ihrer Kinder
die Lehrerin der ersten Klasse beschrieb
die Explosion gegenüber einem Reporter
als schreckliches Erdbeben ist er aus
als würde der Boden mehrere Zentimeter
in die Luft springen
nach dem ersten Schock war ich für einen
Moment wie blind was ich dann sah schien
als wäre die Luft angeführt mit Kindern
Pflegenden Tischen und Büchern die
Kinder wurden hoch in die Luft
geschleudert einige wurden aus dem
Gebäude katapultiert auf dem
Schulgelände herrscht blankes Chaos
überall wuseln Helfer und verzweifelte
Angehörige um unter ihnen ist auch
Andrew kihow der Besitzer des Hofes der
kurz sofort in Flammen aufgegangen ist
wo kommt der denn jetzt her will er
helfen warum ist er nicht auf seiner
Farm
es ist jetzt etwa 9 Uhr 15 und es wird
klar dass hier kein Unglück passiert ist
nicht eine technische Panne oder
Naturkatastrophe hat gleichzeitig den
Hof und die Grundschule ereilt sondern
die Tat eines Wahnsinnigen als
pharmakira auf dem Schulgelände den
Direktor Emmerich trifft richtet er sein
Gewehr auf das eigene Auto und drückt ab
das Geschoss trifft eine Bombe die im
Fahrzeug deponiert ist die Explosion die
dritte an diesem Mittwoch Morgen
verursacht ein weiteres Blutbad Splitter
und Eisen Fragmente töten Kios selbst
den Schuldirektor ruhig den Postboten
von Bars dessen Schwiegervater und einen
Schüler okay sorry Moment ich glaube wir
müssen hier einmal kurz sacken lassen
wir befinden uns in der
US-amerikanischen Provinz im Jahr 1927
morgens ab viertel vor neun hat hier
etwas stattgefunden dass wir eigentlich
erst viele Jahrzehnte später in der
Häufigkeit und der Dramatik so wie hier
kennenlernen werden ich meine hier gab
es zwei schwere Sprengstoffanschläge auf
einen Hof und ein öffentliches Gebäude
und dann noch ein Selbstmordattentat mit
einem extra dafür präparierten Auto ja
Toni wirklich ein absolutes
albtraum-szenario sowas gab es später
bei Anschlägen von al-Qaida oder dem is
oder so aber in Bars Michigan ein Kaff
mit 3000 Einwohnern
und das auch noch Ende der 1920er Jahre
also was muss da vorher passiert sein
und was hat es mit dem Farmbesitzer auf
sich der da gerade sich selbst und den
Schuldirektor in die Luft gejagt hat
Andrew Philip keyho wird am 1 Februar
1872 in die kamste Michigan in einer
Großfamilie mit 13 Kindern geboren sein
Vater philipp ist Farmer seine Mutter
Mary starb als er noch klein war
überhaupt gibt es schon sehr früh viel
Drama in Andrews Leben oh ja zum
Beispiel sein Vater der heiratet wieder
aber mit seiner Stiefmutter versteht er
sich überhaupt gar nicht als er 14 Jahre
alt ist wird Erzeuger eines feuerdramas
im Haus seine Stiefmutter Frances
entzündet den Ofen und verursacht dabei
eine Explosion
Andrew will sie mit Wasser löschen aber
dass das keine gute Idee ist
Öl in Flammen das verschlimmert alles
nur
Francis er liegt ihren schweren
Verbrennungen wenig später die Ursache
der Explosion des Ofens bleibt ungeklärt
aber Jahre später wird man fragen ob
Andrew hier in mörderischer Absicht
seine Finger im Spiel hatte muss ich
kurz zwischen Haken ist natürlich jetzt
wirklich reine Spekulation und nur weil
er später so ein Attentat verübt hat tja
weiß ich nicht ob man dem da jetzt
unterstellen muss das zu dem Zeitpunkt
auch schon
töten wollte oder gemordet hat ja klar
aber das ist natürlich in so einer
Kleinstadt immer schön Klatsch und
Tratsch Klatsch und Tratsch okay
nach seinem Schulabschluss lernt der
Junge kiho Elektrotechnik in dieser Zeit
zieht er sich bei einem Sturz seine
schwere Kopfverletzung zu er liegt
mehrere Wochen im Koma in seiner
Studienzeit lernt kiho auch seine
spätere Frau kennen Alan Agnes Preis
Spitzname Nelly die beiden heiraten 1912
da ist Andrew schon 40 Jahre alt
1919 beziehen Sie die große Farm am
Rande von Bars die ihnen Nellys Onkel
überlässt dafür zahlen sie 6000 $ in bar
die restlichen 6000 $ Schulden sie dem
Onkel weiterhin 12.000
$ insgesamt also das entspricht heute
einem Wert von mehr als 300.000 Euro
damals ein Vermögen die Kios hatten also
spät geheiratet und blieben kinderlos
dennoch galten sie in der Gemeinde als
anständige Leute auch wenn Andrew
einigen Nachbarn wohl ziemlich schullich
vorkam er machte sich bei der Farmarbeit
nicht gern schmutzig und wechselte
deshalb auch öfter die Kleidung und was
bei mir durchaus Sympathien Weg Andrew
versucht ständig sich die Feldarbeit mit
irgendwelchen selbst erfundenen
Maschinen leichter zu machen nur dass er
darin offenbar nicht so talentiert ist
scheiterten Kniff lässt er das
betreffende Feld wohl einfach brach
liegen das berichtet zumindest ein
Nachbar über Andrews versucht gleich
zwei Nähmaschinen hinter seinem Traktor
zu kuppeln im Nachhinein gibt es auch
sehr beunruhigende Eindrücke von Andrew
so solle ein Pferd das ihm nicht
gehorchte totgeprügelt haben bei
Meinungsverschiedenheiten auch mit
seiner Frau Nelly war Andrew schnell
ungehalten und ruppig aber trotz allem
war Andrew in der Gemeinde geachtet und
engagiert sich schließlich in der
Kommunalpolitik wir finden ihn in den
Originalquellen mal als Kassenwart der
Schulküche mal als Vorsitzenden des
schulkomitees nehmen wir einfach mal an
dass er heute zum Schulausschuss des
kommunalparlaments gehören würde fest
steht man schätzt Ihnen dieser Funktion
weil er als sparsam gilt nur dass der
Mann langsam abdreht als noch ein
Schicksal Schlag dazukommt seine Frau
Nelly erkrankt an Tuberkulose die damals
noch als unheilbar gilt außerdem rechnet
sich sein Hof nicht oder ehrlicher
gesagt seine Art den Hof zu führen
steuert das Paar in die Pleite Nellys
Onkel stellt fest dass die kehhaus mit
ihren lehensraten in Verzug kommen aber
Andrew sucht die Schuld nicht bei sich
er behauptet zu hohe Gemeindesteuern
trieben ihn in den Ruin also schlägt er
ständig vor der Schule das Geld zu
kürzen die Klassen zu verkleinern die
Schulkantine sparsamer zu betreiben und
er streitet sich regelmäßig mit dem erst
33 Jahre alten Schuldirektor
in den Jahren 1926 und 27 spitzt sich
die Lage in jeder Hinsicht für Andrew
keyho zu die Gemeinde Steuern sind gegen
seinen Widerstand erhöht worden auf
Betreiben des Onkels kündigt die Bank
das Darlehen für die Farm der
Gesundheitszustand seiner lungenkranken
Frauen erley verschlechtert sich und bei
der Abstimmung über einen weiteren
kommunalen Posten verliert er boah hier
hat sich der perfekte Sturm
zusammengebaut ich fasse das mal kurz
zusammen für uns Andrew keyho ist schlau
technisch begabt und als Elektriker
ausgebildet er ist kreativ aufbrausend
und rechthaberisch und er glaubt dass
alle anderen an allem schuld sind also
der verschwenderische Schuldirektor die
verfressenen Kinder in der Mensa die
Gemeinderäte die um die Steuern erhöht
haben genau der Mann will Rache und das
Vorhaben ist groß und die Gelegenheit
lustig denn als guter Handwerker erhält
er den Auftrag Instandhaltungsarbeiten
am Schulgebäude zu erledigen keho hat
wochenlang ungestört Zugang und da er
Pharma ist gelten auch seine vielen
Bestellungen der Sprengstoffe pyrotol
und Dynamit als unverdächtig denn damit
Räumen damals viele Bauern Bäume aus dem
Weg ab Mitte 1926 beginnt er damit
insgesamt mehr als eine Tonne Pyro Tool
zu kaufen später erwirbt er in einem
Sportgeschäft auch noch zwei Kisten
Dynamit außerdem klaut er offenbar auch
beträchtliche Mengen an einer
Brückenbaustelle
welche wahnsinnigen Ausmaße seine
Vorbereitungen angenommen haben das
zeigt sich erst am verhängnisvollen 18
mai 1927 zunächst tötet er seine Frau
Nelly die gerade erst aus dem
Krankenhaus wieder zurück nach Hause
gekommen ist wie genau er sie umbringt
bleibt unklar ihre Leiche kann später
nur noch in verkohlten Fragmenten
geborgen werden er lässt sie auf der
Farm zurück und fährt mit seinem Auto
los die Ladefläche des Pickup ist über
und über mit Sprengstoff beladen darauf
hat er noch extra Metallteile gelegt
damit sie als tödliche Geschosse
umherfliegen
er zündet seine mit Sprengstoff und
Brandbeschleunigern präparierte Farm an
und fährt zum westlichen Ortsrand von
Barf und wartet ab denn er hat zwei
Zeitzünder an der Schule angebracht
dafür hat sich der gelernte Elektriker
eine Konstruktion mit Weckern ausgedacht
gegen 8 Uhr löst der Zünder im Nordteil
der Schule wie geplant eine gigantische
Explosion aus
der Schaden ist katastrophal 38
Grundschulkinder und sechs Erwachsene
kommen ums Leben 58 weitere Menschen
werden zum Teil schwer verletzt die
Szenen die sich an diesem Vormittag auf
dem Schulgelände abspielen sind
dramatisch verzweifelt und
herzzerreißend
Feuerwehrleute Nachbarn Ärzte und
Krankenschwestern geben ihr Bestes
überall suchen Eltern nach ihren Kindern
ein Vater der schon die Leichen zweier
seiner Kinder gefunden hatte findet
schließlich das dritte ebenfalls
erschlagen von Steinen und Balken des
Gebäudes
viele Eltern nehmen die Leichen ihrer
Kinder mit nach Hause bei dem
Bergungsarbeiten zeigt sich im Südflügel
das keyhode eine zweite Explosion
geplant hatte im Keller liegen weitere
230 Kilo Sprengstoff zum Glück hat hier
die Zündung versagt die Bewohner von
Bars die Menschen im Bundesstaat
Michigan das ganze Land alle fragen sich
warum Andrew keyho so viele Menschen
getötet hat wann er auf die irrsinnige
Idee kam die Schule in die Luft zu jagen
weshalb er den Verstand verloren
selbst und seine Frau können nicht mehr
befragt werden beide sind tot aber
Nachbarn erinnern sich jetzt dass ihnen
der Schräge Tüftler von dem an schon
länger noch verrückter vorkam als zuvor
einem liegt ein Pferd und forderte es
nicht zurück er bewirtschaftete die
Felder nicht mehr sein Nachbarin war
deshalb davon überzeugt dass kiho sein
Selbstmord plante unternahm aber nichts
das Land weint mit den Opfern und
Angehörigen für eine gewisse Zeit wird
der Sprengstoff pyotol verboten am 22
August drei Monate nach dem
Bombenanschlag stirbt die
Viertklässlerin Beatrice Gibbs nach
einer Hüftoperation ihr Tod ist der 45
und letzte der direkt auf die
Katastrophe der bergstuhl zurückzuführen
war aber die USA vergessen schnell
das Geschehen in Bars war einfach zu
schrecklich aber zum Glück bietet
Charles Lindbergh mit seinem
Nonstop-Flug über den Atlantik eine
Ablenkung ab dem 21 mai bestimmt er die
Schlagzeilen aber schon bald wird der
Superstar selber im Zentrum meines bösen
Kriminalfalls stehen einem Fall der
nichts mit dem Massaker von Bert zu tun
hat aber der als das Lindberg Baby
ebenfalls in die Geschichte eingehen
sollte und den erzählen wir euch in der
nächsten Folge
das unglaubliche Massaker von Bart wurde
schon sehr früh vom örtlichen
heimatronisten mjsworth als Buch im
Eigenverlag zusammengefasst als
Standardwerk gilt auch barfensäcke
America Sport School bombing von Anni
burning wir haben in einem Artikel des
Kollegen Florian stark von der Welt
einen guten Überblick gefunden er heißt
ich sah die Körper meiner Kinder gegen
die Wände fliegen
den Link findet